now you've been living under a rock or
trapped in the corn maze corn kid broke
the internet when he was asked to
describe his favorite food check it out
I really like
like cocoon it's cold it's awesome you
describe corn to someone who's never
tasted it before
a bit more beautiful thing it's cold
it's cold cold I hope you will have a
contastic day
well we have a very special guest I'm
Starstruck already ladies and Gentlemen
please welcome the cone kids oh my God
it's cold there is it's calm what's up
bud there he is oh listen man I'm
amazing yes you are amazing yes you are
first of all I'm loving the tooth I see
what you did there man yeah yeah you
grew it in grew it in now Tariq you can
be honest with us do you still like corn
or are you kind of sick of it by now I
still love cold yeah it's got the juice
yeah I know come on now you know
little buttons little buttons with knobs
yes you got these I know what it is it's
so exciting I get to meet the actual
Kian and cow like I'm so funny might
make me cry
yeah but the good thing is I mean we
both here to go ahead and ask me would
you see that I did
you know
you literally messed up Caden's
girlfriend's battle
oh my God so what do you think of a guy
named Kevin Hart you heard of you heard
of Kevin Hart before
you know you know Kevin Hart he did
Jumanji with with the rock and
um
is such a big fan of Kevin Howard oh
nice but Gina that's what okay now you
were in the Macy's day parade what was
the Jolly Green Giant like is he a nice
guy yes okay good short answer for that
one wait I forgot one
uh-huh I would love to say hi to your
sister but I'm just trying to be clear
are you a fan or not like what's
happening man
you'll probably know this cow but
I never even knew Kevin Hart until you
told me this is this this is this is
Kevin Hart here calling me Kim I know
but I'm Kim you're a Kevin Hart no he
thinks that this is Nickelodeon and you
and I are doing a Nickelodeon some good
burger or all that you need to set him
straight okay no I'm serious man I'm
getting hot listen uh Tariq uh just a
just a sidebar come closer to the camera
yeah so I can whisper in you
this is this Kevin Hart right here Kevin
Kevin is really really famous powerful
so you got to give him his respect and
his prop say it say you like Jumanji
that's all you got to say yeah man okay
but like are you like fun you go because
you literally all the cow okay all right
yeah okay somebody just somebody just
lost a Year's subscription to come and I
was gonna I was gonna call you I was
gonna mix you with lots of a whole bunch
of corn tyrik we are so happy for you
and all the successes you've had more
importantly what we love is that you
would just be yourself this is Kel
signing out
absolutely absolutely
foreign